I think he has a healthy respect for the
First Amendment and he this is you know
this is what makes our country so
beautiful is it a one day you can
inaugurate a president on the next day
people can occupy the same space to
protest something but he's also
cognizant to the fact that a lot of
these people were there to protest an
issue of concern to them and not against
anything I remember this morning Debbie
Dingell was on television and you know
she's talking about let me just don't
want to inactivate quote her I know
Jonathan's a stickler for that he said
different women were there for different
reasons but they were all there to make
sure that their core American values are
going to be protected and I think many
people like me were there for positive
reasons and I think the president shares
Debbie Dingles views that there were
people that came to the mall as they do
all the time sometimes in smaller
numbers and so I think he reaches out to
him in the way that he started on the
night that he won the election on the
way that he did on Inauguration Day by
sending a message that talks about
fighting for them but more importantly I
think the president's going to show
through action and through success that
he's fighting for them and fighting for
every American one of the things that
we've seen so often in this town is a
lot of soaring rhetoric about how much
people care and I think the president is
going to show through deed in action and
success that he wants to fight for
people's health care he wants to have a
better education system he wants a
stronger America he wants to go in and
fix our inner cities he wants to make
sure that our infrastructure our roads
and our bridges so I think more than
anything showing people through action
indeed in success is where he's going to
prove the American people how much he
cares to unite us and how much he cares
to make this America better and safer